what is the Classic Hollywood Story or
story structure that every filmmaker
slash writer should know I think
plenty of people have said it better
than me you know the hero's journey
Christopher Vogler
um I think understanding the archetypes
of well first that classic 3x structure
which is the setup the confrontation the
resolution and watching a cat and being
introduced to a character in their world
as they are experiencing it having them
deal with
whatever inciting incident challenges
them and makes them rise to action and
then obviously
um the resolution where we see how the
Journey of act two has impacted them and
will
affect their life and the lives of those
closest to them as they move
past the world of our film
um
you know I think that's something you
have to understand because it's
really where most storytelling exists
and how and then in turn how most people
are used to
absorbing and digesting a story so
learning what works before you break the
rules is important
um
I think that there are other you know
then then you just get into you know
more particular understandings of
character and structure
um
that
hero's journey book by Vogler is great
because he breaks down like you know the
character archetypes from
um you know the I might misquote some of
these people but like you've got allies
you've got
um you've got the shape shifters you
know the people who are introduced as
allies perhaps but then they have
ulterior motives
um whether driven by plot or driven by
character like all of these things are
are helpful to make you kind of look at
the world of
your story and begin to like pick up the
right tool to craft it into something
that best
um
realizes whatever your themes and your
points are that you're trying to trying
to accomplish
um
so I feel like that's that's really the
key
um then if you are
I think that Robert McKee's book
obviously has like a really great story
triangle that was just one element of
the book that but it was very
um I'm a visuals person and so I think
in his triangle he has like you know at
the top of the triangle is
um
the Classic Hollywood narrative that
we're talking about now at the bottom is
um the anti-hero anti-hero you know like
a Travis Bickel and taxi driver and then
at the bottom on the other side is the
uh the multiple character story like a
magnolia or anything Robert Allman and
the joke that he makes is as you move
down the triangle your audience gets
smaller you know and I think that's true
you know unless you have a movie star in
it and you can make Magnolia you know
or crash or you know whatever it might
be right
um but yeah understanding those things I
think is important to being able to
have some agency and control over the
story while still you know being
responsive to what the characters tell
you needs to happen
did you watch Casablanca again after you
took McKee's class oh yeah I've tried
I've watched it often yeah okay yeah and
did you see it with new eyes once you
once you took his class definitely I saw
it with new eyes you know you start
there's there's like
I can enjoy something
while watching
watching you know the sausage being made
you know what I mean like I can watch
like oh I see what they're doing I see
why they did that in that scene and that
was still you know it was very
economical it was still character driven
and that was a smart way to do it in
1941. you know what I mean uh or even
now like I'm watching uh we're watching
Top Boy on Netflix and there are just
certain things that kind of have to
happen in the story and when they happen
I'm watching and I'm like ah that was a
very smart way to do something that has
to happen and so when you know the mile
markers that's when you can begin to you
know add your own perspective add your
own sauce you know your old your own
interpretation and make it unique but
you can't if you don't know that that
mile marker is happening
you know you can't do it at all you know
a bad example would be like if you were
a vegan you have to know what certain
elements are doing in a non-vegan dish
to then say we need this thing to
accomplish what cheese would accomplish
you know what I mean and so like
the architecture of Storytelling you've
gotta you've got to have a you got to be
fluent
when you went to direct uh was it some
of the later episodes of you of you I
did
um episode 307 and 308 so that was
um
third season episode seven and eight out
of ten total episodes
so did you go and re-watch and really
study who these characters are because
they're very very clear interesting
characters fascinating yeah with any
show I'll go and I mean some shows make
it impossible because they have too many
seasons but
um with you I watched every I probably
watched every episode twice
um because I'm watching for
um style I'm watching for and that could
be from the writing to the to the tone
how they handle different moments
whether it's you know violence or sex or
um you know uh camera uh
nowadays how are you applying text you
know and then being on a phone because
that's a whole other thing you know
um and I'm just trying to digest
it's like the information's already
there for me to to start from so I'm
just trying to take it all in
um a lot of times I I might notice like
oh well you used to do this thing in
season one and you know it's not really
happening anymore
um is that like why did you step away
from that and sometimes you're like oh
that was the thing we hated or maybe
they might say oh you know what that was
cool
I don't know why we aren't doing that
anymore let's do that you know so I'm
trying to like information is key
um and then you know I'll read any and
all scripts up to my episode because
some things won't be finished
so you know in a scenario like that you
might have
I could watch maybe two episodes you
know 301 and 302 and then I've got to
read three four five and six to know
where we are in the story and then
figure out what
is happening in my episode and then I've
got to have questions about where it's
going so I I'm aware if I'm setting up
anything in particular for
the final two
sure and a lot of chance meetings in a
show like that and and a lot of
characters uh lying and not revealing
themselves which is sort of
you know the audience is privy to it but
the other characters aren't right and
that show you know last little inside
for for the directors out there that
show was an interesting challenge that I
didn't foresee which is
blocking
for Joe for Pam badgley's character
where
when we're in his mind and he's got his
thoughts blocking in a way where he can
have business and be moving around a
room so those those thoughts can kind of
be private
and he's not compelled to engage with
the other person
so it's like if I'm if if two people are
looking at each other it's a little
weird to have this monologue going that
this voiceover on him while he's really
talking to somebody over here but let's
say I make him take a walk over here get
a plate out of the cupboard his backs to
her he comes back here puts the plate
down and a fork and a knife and then he
looks up that could cover all the vo of
his inner thoughts and so it was a lot
of like really having to think
like the actor and come up with pitches
that would work for that reason
um and so I'm sure that'll be a skill
that I'll take to something else that I
can't predict